all right Jorge Mr Jorge uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally I
grew up in Lynwood California I was born
in Watts but raised in Linwood not too
far from here
how'd you describe your childhood my
childhood was I've been on the Rough
Side given that I I would like to call
it normal but uh most of my upbringing
consisted of trying to avoid gang
banging being that my cousins and my
uncles all grew up gang banging and
tried to bully us into it and make us
fight each other and that kind of opened
me up to wanting to stay away from it
so so you never gave in no no I had
unfortunately brothers and other cousins
that came into it and I saw my
opportunity uh moving forward to just
kind of try to find a different the
opposite if you will that's what led me
to like get more involved into trying to
join law enforcement
and uh As I Grew Older
I mean you know you you get the whole
trying to raise your get your own family
and whatnot so once I got opportunity
and I found out the police department
was hiring over in Texas I went ahead
and uh moved my stuff and I applied and
it went well I went through the academy
and while I was there I
so I I was with a woman and turned out
she she was pregnant so I was there for
about five years and then
it turned out that I got a video from a
person that he let me know that he was
subpoenaed by
the government to show it proof of DNA
and it turned out to be his child and
the child was pretty much ripped out of
my hands I couldn't I couldn't see her
no more by law or anything like that so
I'll try to do my best and join the
Forbes I joined the army and I was there
for a bit and I got I got stabbed during
enforce and that's how I was introduced
to opiates and I never was given
anything to Psycho off and
and that is addictive addiction of mine
you know my mom with me and I was just
trying to scrape what I can to get us
through and it's it's been very rough
and I don't mean to break down like this
and rush into it but
at the beginning of that story he just
so the the child that you thought was
yours it turned out not to to be mine
and this is after me being in the
emergency and being in the delivery room
cutting the umbilical coming down for
vacations being around my child she was
a Filipino ethnicity so I the child
looked a lot more Filipino than anything
so I really never paid attention to it
not looking like mine you know and if it
wasn't for that if it wasn't for the DVD
for the for the video that I was sent
through Facebook I would have never
raised suspicions I'm not the jealous
type to
to not keep someone from going out with
their friends or whatnot so everything
just fell on me I I bothered her we we
had a condo I wasn't leasing I was
running to own I got her own car and
everything and I think it was dumb of me
too that I'd give her a certain
percentage when I left that place I
really needed family support I had no
one there I want to come down here it
wasn't even a couple months later until
my mother's husband passed away and
things just crumbled there was like a
Snowball Effect and my grandmother
passed away like three months ago and I
had a little cash saved up and we needed
to pay for the funeral so that went down
the drain too and
it's just been rough and
I have PTSD not just because of child
but because of the military too and
having nightmares of of me like having
the child literally ripped from my hands
of I have my mother have to wake me out
of the dream and
it's just been rough for me lately you
know it's been rough for me for the last
couple of years actually and
you've worked in law enforcement yes sir
I worked in law enforcement out in Texas
for the Texas Department of Criminal
Justice and
I I thought I was doing the right thing
and everything I mean I straight away
and I came back and those people that
weren't supposed to be in my life it
worked even better because I was an
officer or a pig if you want to call it
they would just stay away from me so I
didn't have to deal with that whole
bullying or you're in the gang now even
if you don't want to be because we're
family and they literally that worked
for me in that favor and now that this
happened it's like
they look at me and they look down onto
me like look at all the right things you
try to do the things you believe in and
look how it turned out for you and I'm
trying to stay positive you know and
it's just hard to when when all these
negative things are happening and I'm
just I was trying to do the best I could
you know I'm the only son out of all my
brothers and sisters that actually went
through it actually graduated from high
school and went to try to do something
positive and here we are you know where
are you staying now I've stayed out of a
van unfortunately really we were able to
scrape up to get the van and that's
where my mother and I are living at my
brothers really didn't weren't paying
attention to my mom that much and
I I thought I could help her out for the
time being and what I told you about my
grandmother passing away I had to give
out that savings and I couldn't pay my
rent anymore the little test that I had
we we bought a van and we've been living
there out of it ever since
and that's been for about a year and
some change now
it's all here on drugs or anything like
that no sir no drugs no as of I mean I I
I want to be as open as I can with you I
have my battle with with opiates here
and there being that they didn't give me
anything to Psycho off and it's been a
rough one because it's one thing for
your mind to say that you don't want to
do it it's another thing when the body
is craving certain things and I have my
rough times where like I'm I'm falling
down and I know what my body's asking me
for but if I give in to it which I have
in the past it's just
it just leads to more and more and more
and more and I can't do anything if I'm
not if I'm not functioning 100 and
that's being truthful with you that's
one of my worst things that the
addiction issue is I'm trying to battle
it and trying to keep from
it's
what do you think the biggest problem in
your life now is it is it the drug
addiction my biggest problem consists of
finding self-worth and self-value being
the
I feel that was totally for me I feel
like I value myself a whole lot more
when I had all these things so I feel
like I just have to Value myself as a
person so that I don't have to do it for
nobody else and I'm doing it for myself
thank you
I love you to find that I know they say
love yourself and or else nobody will
and I feel like that's the issue with me
because I gave that relationship I gave
that career my 100 but I don't feel like
I gave myself 100 of what I wanted in
life
and I
it's what I want I want that straight
and narrow path I want their family I
want that American dream and it's like
and it's hard when I don't believe in
myself like I I noticed that about
myself after five people to believe in
me so that I believe in myself and I
don't know how to do it
foreign
[Music]
I'm sorry I didn't mean to break down
like that it's just this is really a
good outlet for me to release it I
haven't told it many people my story for
the same reason I don't think too many
people can cope but you get to opening
up and you realize that we got a lot of
people got their issues too you know
we're just trying to make it through but
a lot of them like to see it in the
right they believe in themselves they
believe in what this number is it's hard
to because I give 100 to what I what I
thought I really believed in and it led
me to a to a dead end
everything taken from me and like I've
given so much to people and it's
I don't have anything much left on
myself I'm not talking about financial
I'm just talking about my self-worth I
don't feel like I have much left anymore
what's your biggest fear now
biggest fears
I really believing
on the on the on these negative thoughts
that I get on this down downsides that I
get about myself like my biggest flaw is
really giving in to the temptation of of
me thinking that that little 10 minute
30 minute high of me being on opiates or
me just ignoring the world and laying in
bed with depression that's my biggest
fear so I try to get up every morning
and try to just get the day going as
early as possible because if not then I
just spend days there just depressed and
just
thinking about everything and that's
like I'm creating my own help is is the
deeper problem your depression it's it's
I feel like it's it's the
if anything the the root of of of all my
issues it would be the depression being
I gotta tell you if I don't believe in
myself if I don't trust in my own self I
gotta ask for reassurance from other
people I have to even if it's something
that I'm sure of I still feel iffy about
it's just hard to explain but it's like
I need reassurance and all that and I
don't know I'm too old to be like oh I
need a father or a figure or whatnot but
I can tell psychologically why why
there's a big difference between a
single parent home and a two-parent home
yeah like missing a father where there
would have been a a bad example or
whatnot there's just things a father can
teach you and things that a father can
show you in regards to self-value and
things like that where it's like you're
a man no matter what you're gonna you're
gonna be able to get through it because
you're a man things like that I didn't
grow up in my life and I could see that
in my friends that did that did have a
father and I could see how they believe
in themselves even when there's nothing
working for them you know and that's the
biggest issue I feel I I'm dealing with
[Music]
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
uh
not hold too many burdens not hold too
many grudges and pretty much not not
think and Ponder and about my mistakes
and what things that happened if they
happen
I wish I could just be like other people
and say boohoo okay like suck it up and
keep going but these are things that I
don't if it wasn't for this
venue where I can just vent I I I'm
Mexican so my my my whole family or just
hit me with that machismo thing that
you don't don't mental health is not a
it's not a reality for any of my family
members so me speaking to them they're
just gonna I've been laughed at I've
been ridiculed I
I
I've been left pretty much like
in the gutter left side and it's like
all I'm asking is for help and they just
make me feel less of a man for needing
help from other people
foreign
you've had some terrible breaks
yes sir
Daddy's
at least my life has been a little bit
rough especially when I'm just trying to
do the right thing and it's heaven and
it's not like I just speak about it I
have done these things I'm telling you
my true life story and I just felt like
nothing gives nothing gives I mean I was
doing the right thing and
I felt like I wasn't doing them for me I
felt like that was my biggest mistake
hearing myself talking right now I just
feel like I was doing everything for
something else and not for me I know
like if the child would have been mine
that would have been something that I
would have to do
regardless but it would have been mine
you know it would have been mine and
it's like everything I do I just feel
like I just get stepped on or like used
in some way or another by by someone
else you know my brothers used to ask me
for help and I'd help them but now it's
my turn to her and it's like dude you're
a grown man you should be able to do it
by yourself I've never
thought I would get that reciprocation
from them being that I would help I just
feel like excuse my language like I'm a
dumbass sometimes you know and it's I I
just don't know what's wrong with me on
that field
but
I'm trying to work through it I think I
might have to get a counselor or
something to be able to work those
issues out
and when I was in the military I was
getting constantly like that but there's
only so much you can tell them before
they put a red flag and they don't let
you work anymore things of that nature
so I wasn't able to open up completely
because then it's it's it's off the
field and on to retirement you go by
force you know and
I I couldn't afford that when when I had
my mom still at home waiting for me to
send money back home and things of that
nature so
it's just
how do you support yourself now living
in a van uh I Panhandle as as much as I
can I I run into a lot of people that
that uh do boosting and I've I I was
used without knowing as well like oh
come inside the store with me and then
like I'll take this back or bring my
other purse I forgot the wrong one once
I caught on to it it's like dude this
it's not something I feel comfortable
with it's I'd rather panhandle my way
they are good people out in the earth
that will help you out it just uh now
now I'm in the works of I'm getting my
ID already situated my license I just
passed the test for California so I'm
getting ready to gotta win and get the
wheels in motion grease them up a bit
and just get back to working to to
Corporate America because that's the
only way that I feel
it's the best way to live this the
streets are not for anyone period you
know it's a very cold world out there in
it uh my mother for the grace of God
that she's been sticking with it she's
been there and it's just I don't know
how much she can take as well I don't
know how much I can take alone that's
what scares me the most like I failed
and
she goes down the drain with me and I
I can't afford that I can't afford
another setback I can't I just that's
where me believing in myself and
understanding that I'm doing everything
for myself comes into play like
if I just find another reason or if I
just do it all because of my mother we
all gotta expiration date and when she
passes away what am I gonna break down
again am I am I going to throw it all
away am I so it's it's
it's one step at a time so I feel like
counseling would be the best thing that
I I need to get but
I'm just trying to get back to corporate
in America to the real world
is fentanyl your drug now uh yes
unfortunately yes with all these laces
going on here and there like without me
knowing I I I got hooked on to it
it's regret
no I'm being weak-minded to be truthful
being weak-minded and and thinking I
need certain things that I don't when a
reality
everything's gonna everything has a
little bit of ups and down to it so I
don't have to run
or or sound the alarm every time
something's happening that's not going
my way I feel like my biggest regret is
that like
not having the tough outer shell to be
able to just
go with certain flows you know like go
with life if you will
do the turmoils of Life the ups and
downs I just feel like once things hit
the fan
I just sound the alarm and just panic
and
here comes the drugs you know here here
comes a the the denial of what I'm doing
that's supposed to help me is not
helping me it's pretty much going down
the drains like
that I have I'm very grateful for my mom
because she keeps me as much as I
possibly can on a straight and narrow
and
and I feel like
that alone
with the with me trying to get it with
me trying to get that outer shell that
tough outer shell it'll come in a lot
more easier than me being out here in
the streets and if something bad happens
oh well let's go run back to the drugs I
just need to get away from it all away
from this place and that's why I want to
go back to Texas and just continue what
I was doing out there if I'm able to
that's for sure that's that's the main
thing that's the main objective
foreign
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
love yourself and nobody will
find yourself value because nobody else
is gonna if you leave it up to somebody
else to tell you what you're worth
they're gonna use they're gonna put
their stamp on it their PR their price
on you or what they love you
for and you're gonna realize you're not
gonna matter to people as much as you
would matter for yourself
okay thank you so much for sharing your
story I appreciate you and you're doing
you're doing a great job right here this
it's it's like
believe it or not it's like counseling
you're literally I don't haven't said
this to many people not even to my mom
that's why I was a little bit iffy here
but
I just felt like I can I released a lot
right here you know so
I'm definitely after having this session
with you I'm definitely gonna seek out
counseling I've been neglectful and I've
been ignoring it because everybody
thinks you're gonna go like myself
personally honestly I don't want to be
labeled a certain thing or go to the
Looney Bin if you will but this has made
me feel open that I won't be judged if I
open up about my situation no I think
that can be very helpful thank you so
much sir especially in your situation
thank you all right okay thank you so
much thank you thanks